hey everybody my name is chef marcus
samson from the red rooster today i'm
really honored to be here as part of
black history month we're going to do
tips tips it's a traditional ethiopian
dish that can be made with either beef
or lamb tips is also a great dish you
can find late at night so a couple of
main components that you need with tips
first of all you need injera bread like
a sourdough pancake this goes on the
bottom of the plate stir fry goes on top
of it and then you break small pieces
like this and you scoop it all up as i
cook it's gonna all make sense spiced
butter is something that we use almost
in all ethiopian cooking the key thing
with the spiced butter is obviously
butter right but it's the ingredients
that we add to it so
onion that we cook off
i have garlic
add ginger
cumin
you get the point we're really going to
flavor this butter at both
oregano
and cardamon turmeric
and fenugreek and
make lots of it this butter will never
go bad it can flavor enhance any dish
you make sometimes people put in their
hair some people put it on the skin and
sometimes people even put it in coffee
as the butter
is separating
to clarify that you want to skim it and
it looks like this and this is basically
the milk product here that you want to
separate
this allows it for you to cook it on
much higher heat the color should look
really bright and yellow older this
butter you get
just like a wine it gets better and
better to make this tips you need a
little bit of greens we're just going to
chop it down
you want something that stands up
against the rich beef and the rich
butter i'm ethiopian but i'm really
sweet opia right because i was born in
ethiopia but raised in sweden so i
actually learned ethiopian food very
late in life and most of the ethiopian
cooking i know i threw notes from my
wife when her sisters find out that i do
ethiopian food they fly in
you go to ethiopia food no no no don't
embarrass us do that other food that you
do
so this my friend is a tenderloin of
beef and we're actually using the head
because it's actually separated here
into
two different parts right but for dips
it doesn't matter we're not going to
cook it whole it actually helps us
in ethiopia eating meat is a luxury it's
something that you eat on big holidays
whether it's weddings or spiritual
holidays very often when you have a big
party
you give away a goat you have to call
your goat pimp have that in your phone
i'm not joking the tips that you see
late night is very often in ethiopia
right around bars that's where the cab
drivers are that's where the good eats
are that's where i go
so i'm cutting into cubes like this very
simple pieces and there's really no bad
parts of this but it's super lean you
can do this with flank steak as well
much more affordable but why not black
history month let's celebrate now it's
time to sear it i'm just going to pour a
little oil in and again i have a little
bit sort of leftover pieces we're not
going to throw them out the fat the good
flavor is going to come from that right
we're just going to put that in and
season our pan right so we're using
everything you know we'll be happy your
grandmother the pan is hot
salt
a little bit of pepper
and this guy this is the barbra berbera
is used is our salt and pepper it's used
in everything berber is an ethiopian
spice blend chili pepper
cardamon
sauce dried garlic dried ginger it's all
in there and it's really the thing that
when you've had ethiopian food
this is what you're gonna remember this
is actually even a currency in ethiopia
so i'm putting a good amount on it on
top
i'm keeping this on a high eight and i'm
just gonna coat my meat oh the smells in
the aromas are absolutely
amazing right i smell home when i've
been away on a trip
and i open my door and i miss something
it's very often
the smell of berbere and now do not
clean up the pan we're going to use the
same pan because all the juices and
flavors are in here
i'm going to add in
my broccoli rub and this could be
kale mustard green bottom of the pan has
all the flavorings right it has the meat
it has the meat drippings it has the
berber we're just going to cook it
pretty quick
now we're actually going to start
building up this dish and we're going to
put a little bit of oil
and the
yellow
it's delicious so this adds flavor
i'm going to start with
onion
nice beautiful red onion sliced garlic
and ginger
the flavor's just gonna build here
so this combination between onion and
ginger garlic is also in so much of
ethiopian cooking but it's just going to
caramelize it gets nice i'm going to add
in rosemary
time to add in a little bit of cumin
i love making ethiopian especially
ethiopian american food because my food
then i'm very often taking ethiopian
stew
and you know adding in like pasta into
that or doing a stir fry there like this
and maybe put an egg on it and put it on
the toast i start very often with
ethiopian ingredients
but
end up somewhere else you see all this
good stuff it's caramelizing the onion
the chilies as we're doing that we're
just going to start add in some sort of
the the wetter stuff so this is going to
be a crushed tomatoes vinegar
mustard
berry goes in everything it really is a
way of life the greens that we cooked
off all of that's just gonna simmer
together now the key here is to
rebuilding this right the onions the
garlic needs to cook off the rosemary
all of that is cooking together
simmering together i'm going to add in
the beef now so now we got to work
pretty quick so the meat is in i'm going
to fold in there the
nice
chopped tomato
the last ingredient i'm gonna put in
is a little bit of chopped cilantro and
now it's just giving it a quick stir the
whole process of making tips is around
20 minutes right and we're making food
here now for six to eight people it's a
lot of food it's rich suggest you have
it with a good beer and the cool thing
with a dish like this
is that this will also be
what we're going to eat it from so i'm
just going to put a little bit of
burberry here so just kind of like if
people want more they can go back and
get that i'm going to give them two
different places to do that same thing
with the fresh cheese so this is like
think about this as a ricotta this is a
fresh cheese it's called ibe it's
buttermilk and milk so we're just going
to put that on a couple of places on the
plate so here it's like your different
islands so if you want heat you go over
here if you want to take off heat you
take it over here right so look at this
your tips
is ready
it looks delicious and we're just gonna
serve this on the center
of the plate
and
la la
you're ethiopian dinner
is almost served
alright so this is our tips it's
absolutely delicious
guys jump in
you literally want to break bread here
right you take your piece so you just
break a small piece off like that right
and then you just take your piece go for
it you got to be fast because jason's
going to go in he hasn't gone in hard
i love that you see all the guys are
aggressive they go big the women are
more alcohol
[Music]